تحصل الصين على ما ترغب به
وكذلك الدول الاصغر
ايها السيدات والساده
هذه هي التصرفات التصعيديه
باتت اكثر وقمعيه في داخل الصين
وكذلك في الخارج هناك استنتاجات اساسيه
حول كيف تغير الصين وبالتالي سيترع لك
علينا نحن للتشكيل سياساتنا وكيف يجب ان
يتغير نحن ايضا ولكن اولا
الصين
لم تقلب صفحه
الاصلاح والانفتاح
وتمضي
باتجاه عهد جديد من الامن والسيطره شاهدنا
ذلك مطلع هذا الشهر عندما كرر رئيس
الشيتعهده
بان يجعل الجيش الصيني وانا اقتبس جدار
حديدي عظيم يحمي السياده والامن والمصالح
التنمويه الصينيه
شاهدنا ذلك ما مبادره بكين الامن العالمي
والتي
تعمل ضمن نطاق الامم المتحده ونتوقع ان
نرى تركيز اكبر على الامن خاصه مع
التكنولوجيا العسكريه تصبح اقتصاديه كل
الشركات في الصين على سبيل المثال
ملزمات قانونا
بمساعده عمليات جمع الاستخبارات الوطنيه
وان تبقيها سريه
ولنا ان نتوقع منه حتى الاجراءات الضبط
الاقتصاديا جزء من تعزيزي
اداره الحزب الشيوعي الصيني الاقتصادي
والمؤسساتها وقادتها
ولنا اتوقع ايضا
مسارا واضحا ودفعا
تجاهه جعل الصناعه اعتمادا على العالم
والعالم اكثر اعتمادا على الصين او كما
قال رئيس الشيب بكل صراحه سنوات وانا
اقتبس
الصين يجب ان تضيق اعتمادا الثلاثه
الانتاج العالميه على الصين لتشكيل قدرات
قويه مضاده
وهذا
الحقوا على المعدل الخامس مثل
قطارات سريعه وتكنولوجيا الطاقه المتجدده
او التكنولوجيا الناشئه الاساسيه
للامن القومي والاقتصاد المستقبلي
والحوسبه الكميه وروبوتات وذكاء الاصطناعي
الاستنتاج الثاني الذي حقنا نتوصل اليه
هو ان
من ضرر جدا للامن والسيطره
هنالك منطقي التجاره الحره والاسواق
المفتوحه
وفي تقريره امام مجلس الحزب قال رئيس
الشيل للشعب الصيني ان يستعدوا للمعاناه
او الصراع وليس مصادفه
انه استخدم في كلمته الافتتاحيه كلمه
دوزن وفاندو
وذكرها مرارا وكلاهما يترجم على انهما
صراعه
الى احساسي تشكيل العالم
لمصلحه الصين والذي يصل بي الى الاستنتاج
الثالث
وهو ان الحزمه الشيوعي الصيني هدفه الواضح
هو تغيير منظم
للنظام الدولي تقع الصين في قلبه
شاهدنا ذلك مع مواقف الصين في الحياه
المتعدده الاطراف
واظهرت عزيمه الصين على ترويج رؤيه بديله
للنظام الدولي
حيث حقوق الافراد خاضعه للامن القومي
والامن والاقتصاد سوف تتجاوز الحقوق
المدنيه
شاهدنا ذلك مع طريق
الحزامي والطريق او مبادره الحزام الطريق
والبنوك او المؤسسات التي الاخرى
اعدت لمنافسه النظام الدوليه الحالي
شاهدنا ذلك مع مبادرات الصين الدوليه وكيف
تمركز نفسها كقوه ووسيط السلام مثلا عبر
مبادره او الاتفاق بين ايران والمملكه
العربيه السعوديه
وكذلك اظهرت صداقتها مع موسكو والتي تعبر
بالاف الكلمات عن هذه رؤيه الجديده هي
نظام الدولي الجديد
ايها السيدات والساده
اذا ما تاملنا في كل ذلك فان استجابتنا
يجب ان تبدا
من خلال العمل على تعزيز النظام الدولي
نفسه
نريد ان نعمل مشركائنا المسائل الدوليه
مثل التجاره
والتمويل المستدامه والصحه والمناخ ومن
اجل ذلك علينا تعزيز المؤسسات والانظمه
والتي تستطيع الدول ان تتنافس وتتعاون
فيها ويستفيد جميع منها
ولهذا السبب فمن الضروري جدا
ان نضمن الاستقرار الدبلوماسي
والتواصل المفتوح مع الصين
حتى اقدر بانه ليس من مصلحتي اوروبا ان
تتصل عن الصين
علاقاتنا ليست اما ابيض او اسود
واستجابتنا لا يمكن ان تكون ذلك ايضا
ولهذا السبب فيجب ان نركز على خفض المخاطر
وليس الانفصال
وهذا احد الاسباب التي تدفعني لزياره
باكين عن قريب الى جانب رئيس ماكرون
لاداره هذه العلاقه
وان يكون بيننا التبادل الحوار صريح هو
مفتوح مع الصينيين هو جزء اساسي مما اسميه
خفض المخاطر عبر الدبلوماسيه لعلاقاتنا مع
الصين
[موسيقى]
لن نخجل ابدا
لطرح المسائل المقلقه جدا التي اوضحتها
ولكن يجب ان نترك المجال للحوار